[Music]
you get to shoot guns in the movie i
love pretending to shoot guns yeah
especially in a western it's been a
fantasy of mine i never get to do it
they taught you some stuff right yeah
they did well we had this thing called
cowboy camp where we went for three
weeks and we sort of uh you know they
rode horses for a couple hours shot guns
for a couple hours through lassos for a
couple hours just kind of beat the city
out of us per se do you do you want to
yes i would we have some guns here yeah
yeah do you want to grab a gun yeah yeah
you you grab a gun too okay don't worry
they're loaded
and what do i have to and i just love
the idea that maybe you could show me
just one trick that they taught you what
you want well first you got to get
yourself into like a good cowboy stance
like bow your legs a little bit like
what kind of cowboy are you
all right
drugstore cowboy okay so what you want
to do is you want to pretend that you're
drawing it we are not intimidating
cowboys right is this is this the okay
so these are how our horses move okay
and what you want to do is you want to
imagine that you pull it out of your
holster right spin it up and over and
[ __ ] it okay how did you spin it up and
over how do you do that okay what you
want to do is you want to imagine this
is bad this is pointed right at me
but i just beat you in a gunfight okay
all right all right so you want to use
the weight of the barrel and just let
that pop it down and bring it back
around okay hold on hold on yeah yeah
yeah
you're getting okay
all right
okay
[Applause]
and then you can switch it all around
get it going flip with the other hand
like all that stuff all right i got that
going yeah although
i got that the board one's easier
but then look back now look at that back
down back now
all right you nailed it you know so uh
but what they actually told us was that
anybody who twirls a gun in the gunfight
it will be their last gun fight so it's
kind of like a movie thing yeah because
in real life if guys were there to kill
you and you're like will i think that
maybe you're dead a hundred times
yeah
nobody says let's get out of here he's
twirling it
it's the knee must be good i'm the
masked twirler yeah
all right
there you go
all right thank you very much that's
fantastic
[Applause]
the long ranger
the lone ranger is in theaters oh andy
we got you a gun too
ah nice
[Applause]
it actually shoots eggnog
it's an eggnog repeater